donc ce que vous voyez ici en fait c'est
un système à deux colonnes qui
représente un peu ce qu'on retrouve dans
notre unité donc deux unités une
première unité qui permet de venir
capter le co2 paie une deuxième unité
qui permet de faire de sortir le tube
qu'on a capté donc pour nourrir dans le
fond c'est comme une représentation sur
le système ima et le pommeau un peu pour
un poumon industriel
donc comment ça fonctionne c'est qu'en
fait dans notre système industriel
vous avez ignoré les gars qui
contiennent co2 qui à la base la colonne
puis vous voyez ce qu'il va monter puis
toulon qui vont monter à travers le
support solide qu'on appelle le
garnissage ils vous raconteront liquide
à l'intérieur de ce liquide l'eau nous
on a mis une broche karvonen donc
l'enzyme qui permet de d'absorber
rapidement c'est juste pour vous donner
un petit peu nude à quoi ça ressemble
donc là une brosse carbonique en fait
c'est une peau est quelque chose qu'on
veut sous forme de poudre dans tout ce
qu'on fait c'est combien cette peau de
l'homme à l'intérieur d'un liquide
c'est vraiment la combinaison des deux
qui fait qu'on est capable d'enlever le
co2 dans l'industrie
la solution qu'on utilise est quelque
chose qui se dégradent peau qui est très
stable qui aucune
émissions toxiques alors ce serait
finalement la cesci se reprocher à la
cheminée le fils jean dont voilà c'est
ça par la suite et ça c'est que le
liquide qui vaut à venir si lui se
trouve à avoir capter le co2 qui était
dans le gard ce don qui seraient envoyés
dans le deuxième système où les cette
fois là on va mettre les conditions pour
que l'essai ou deux points et capté lui
ont pu se régénérer de la solution ce
que ça va faire c'est que dans les
flamands gazet l'étape est à 8 10 % de
co2 quand je reçois ici jeu presque 80
même ou de l'autre 99 02 donc ce qui
fait que maintenant j'ai un produit que
je peux utiliser pour différentes
applications
que ce soit dans l'alimentaire dans la
récupération du pétrole non plus
dépendants ou ont été installés des
possibilités